car girl you got your new boobies
sinister
and you're a kind of poacher turned
gamekeeper as it were because you've
ever promo being a critic to being a
screenwriter having you and you started
off at Ain't It Cool News
so what's that change been like for you
well it's been it's been strange but
great I mean it's it's been it's been an
interesting transition you know for ten
years you know I was just immersed in it
and celebrating the love of film and
talking about it and that's actually
been I look at it as kind of like my my
college the my college doctorate and
this is my thesis you know it's it's
been one of those things where I've
really been able to apply a lot of what
I learned as a critic is when I was a
critic I always knew I wanted to write
fiction and whether it was just novel
writing or whether it was screenwriting
I went into every film trying to learn
from it and so over the years I
developed my own theories of
storytelling and filmmaking and now I
get to apply them and so it's been
really interesting at the same time it's
also very interesting to watch the
process from the other side and realize
some of the myths that critics hold and
watching them debunked and then seeing
why certain things are from the other
side so it's been a really cool kind of
eye-opening experience at the same time
your the biggest myths that you found
that you've had your eyes eye open - the
biggest thing is that Hollywood is out
of ideas
Hollywood has nothing but original ideas
there every there are so many great
filmmakers out there that want to tell
original stories and Studios that want
to make them but the problem is is that
audiences don't want to see them and
audiences won't pay to see them and
people say I want something new and
original but at the end of the day
they'll they pay to go see a remake
because they they want to know what
they're getting in advance and so many
critics spend so much time railing on
this notion that
that everyone is out of ideas and can't
come up with anything and the thing is
they have tons of them that they want to
show but nobody wants to pay for them
and so it's been really interesting to
see that process and try to maneuver
that and tell an original story that we
can get audiences to come and see ok
well with that in mind let's talk a
little bit about the state of horror and
what the appeal is of a horror because
obviously sinister is a supernatural
horror movie it's a very very good one
congratulations on that by the way I
mean what do you think the species of
horror currently well I think it's
really exciting right now we've seen a
big turn from the last you know the last
decade had a lot of very realistic
terror and people wanted to they were
very you know we had what what has been
sadly dubbed torture porn where people
wanted maniacs they wanted torturers
they wanted real visceral kind of human
experience and now they've seen so much
of that and it's got had to go so
extreme that they want monsters again
and they want supernatural horror and
they want to see boogie men and they
want to see things that scare them that
are very not real but at the same time
play upon primal fears and so it's it's
that's a really great toy box and ten
years ago you could not get people
necessarily to go see a ghost movie you
know we had a handful that were
successful but really people the idea of
seeing a haunted house movie people were
like really a haunted house to me that's
kind of 1982 and now they're like oh boy
haunted house movie I really I love
those those are great and so it's it's a
great toy box to play around with to
really address people's primal fears and
what really scares them without having
to get more and more grotesque now the
guy who's a lead in this play by Ethan
Hawke isn't it he is a guy who will goes
almost any lengths for a story isn't he
how far would you go for story as a
writer a screenwriter critic not very
far know Ethan is very much his
character Ellison Oswalt is very much
what me and Scott are afraid of becoming
that we both you know I I'm madly in
love with my wife he's not in love with
his wife and his kids and we're
terrified of the notion
giving ourselves silver to our career
that we sacrifice our own family and so
we wrote from that perspective of let's
write the guy that is the guy that we're
afraid of becoming and showing how he
could become that guy and so how far
would I go not marry and there have been
a couple of things that I've gotten
opportunities that I just couldn't take
because of my family and same with Scott
so I would say that this is this is as
much
we're playing upon the audience's fears
as we're playing upon our own so which
you as he does in the film if there's a
noise in the attic or somewhere else or
say it's another film endure in the
basement or something would you go and
investigate or would you hightail out of
there
I would investigate I've actually swear
to god I've been in a horror movie
experience I see this is no BS I was a
camp counselor when I was 17 years old
and we discovered a guy in a mask in one
of the girls cabins over the weekend
when we only had a handful of kids at a
handful of counselors and it became that
sudden going out getting the guns from
the rifle range all holding up at the
house investigating trying to find it
the guys still on the camp and I was one
of those guys who was like let's go find
this guy come on and and you know made a
lot of very silly mistakes that you you
know it's really interesting when you're
in that situation all of a sudden the
logic of these horror movies makes a lot
more sense when you can actually be in
that situation and see just how scared
you are and how stupid you get when
you're that scared these things people
go I would don't go in the cabin why
would you go because the cabin seems
like the safest place at the moment shut
up it's it's actually what you would do
so yeah I know but I am the guy that
when I hear a noise in the Attic it's
like you know my wife's like go look at
it
right I'll do it and go and grab those
you know the flash light the torches you
would call it go in the Attic and get
killed so I'm that guy at least you need
to tell the towel still do you ever say
I'll be right back
never you never say I'll be right back
that is one of the golden rules a fatal
error that would be wouldn't it
you mentioned Scott Derrickson oh of
course he's your co-writer and also
director of this film isn't he and you
met through Ain't It Cool News and you
caught this movie kind of came out
because of a random trip to Las Vegas
didn't it tell me about that yeah no it
was we had been friends for a couple
years he was a fan of my writing he
started writing me I was a fan of his
bill so we started running back and
forth and we ended up in Vegas on the
same weekend and he discovered over
Twitter so he got together for drinks
and five White Russians in he was like
hey I've got this idea bang around my
head can I bounce it off you I said yeah
sure and so he bounced it off me I was
like oh hey that's a great idea it's you
know I'm getting them a few ideas on
that and I said now that you mention it
I have an idea that's been banging
around that I'd love to share with you
is like all right hit me everybody
pitches something to me once this is
your one time and I pitched him sinister
and at the end he said and a week later
we were in Jason Blum's office and jason
blum said I want to make that movie and
eight months later we were making it
incredibly steep across to you hasn't it
what's gonna happen next you think after
sinister well Scott and I are working on
a couple of other things things that we
can't necessarily talk about right now I
have a book coming out here in the UK as
well as in the u.s. Gallants is putting
it out here it's called dreams and
shadows that comes out in January and
that's part of a two-book deal so I'm
spending the summer working on the
follow-up novel to that which should
come out the following January here and
hopefully we'll have another film that
we can talk about shortly
you